Oh got it
feeling a second matter that's just my
name welcome back to guy forgot Torchic
the [ __ ] am i doing seriously focus
Bailey alright yeah man I'm sorry
Torchic
why would you do that Bennett why would
you do
I'm sorry I told you it will never
happen again all right Patti I forgive
you
good oh thank god you can't go here all
right I guess we're going down then I
opted to the game to one point - not
that anyone cares but it was supposed to
freeze if you updated it so let's just
hold our nipples
I mean thumbs funny I think I have a key
oh let's see well I see you there in a
lot you probably can't see it but it's a
barrel there he's gonna [ __ ] up the
loading if you [ __ ] up their loading
bear a [ __ ] up you don't know how I
don't even know how where is good
questing where the [ __ ] do you come from
where's your cheek ah the wine cellar
key should be kept in Section C I need
to fix each barrel [ __ ] wait I don't
even have oh no I don't have torchy okay
I'm out of batteries - that is just
fantastic
okay I'm just stopping by
stop what are you doing making barrels
here - [ __ ] is that barrel cakes I don't
appreciate it
it's lit it you're not getting the
coziness all right okay it's just the
wind fitting that's the way I think were
you back
I'm still trying to look for whatever is
I'm looking for Shh
don't whisper to me I don't like
whispering don't like Oh what is this
story section well you said story
section C but I guess can't hurt delight
I mean there are things to appreciate in
here like this dry
I bet no one's appreciating you dry all
right [ __ ] am i doing in here they're
really there you spend all this time
building this for no reason
okay I'll go to storage section see them
nope what the [ __ ] Oh sister win
illusions it's nothing man okay story
it's gotta be here
ah does it even I stepped a colon scan
that Sun deep sea sky okay it's gotta be
over here custom hey Jenna
whoa okay okay I'm sorry I didn't mean
to take it
I didn't mean to take it I'm sorry it's
gotta be over Shh man I wish is fun over
there all right
you up make it cozy and then what is
this what the key I require is supposed
to be in this section there must be a
way to get this box out of the way maybe
spinning this nothing happened the
machinery ah [ __ ] me it's puzzles I got
I why would you put that day uh mush all
right uh see where this cable is going I
wish I could see all right we have back
in storage section D there's supposed to
be something ah can't believe I missed
it you want it wrong you wanna pin it
don't do it yes yes I went to [ __ ] come
on there we go
[ __ ] [ __ ] all right so I tried to
jump up but apparently you can just
[ __ ] walk around and I need to find
the last lab or mother off the machine
has finally been fixed but the new lever
that operates the door to section C is
still missing I thought you guys put in
Section A install that everywhere god
damn it all right let's just go there
fastest
because I'm kind of tired of these
puzzles not gonna line up gonna live oh
that would limited gross I'm sorry all
right
section a why don't you come to me
because I like yeh game yeah whatever
B all right let's find that level
oh don't ask Oliver is it here where are
you
I don't hear come and approach me girl
gotta be huge gotta be here
where the [ __ ] at the lava way to forget
I forget about labra either [ __ ] it the
never where the [ __ ] is she never what
if or when he what a little ever well
we're and still never I love a parrot
don't have their back where's another I
know you know I know why don't I [ __ ]
alright it's friendly in here and why
didn't would lie about that well what's
going on here it fell over what the hell
is that mr. chair we got it for you
Perry yeah all right I don't know why
they would do that the puzzles are a
little too tricky for my taste
Oh my taker [ __ ] I mean they say
Section eight you would think it isn't
that connect but no it's in section bait
can't you say I like to be on your mama
what the hell that was inappropriate
I mean P is totally offender right now
all right
get plan it straight and count down to
three two one penetration all right
section C should be operative edible
whoa whoa oh no oh no what do i do what
do i do what do i do I do wonder world
what do I do better Bob why do i do what
do i do what
you
yeah this is awesome
come on oh don't break alright super dad
huh all right I'm out of here we have
control room all right
I didn't mean to [ __ ] do it stop my
failure okay so now we go to Section C
be another man there isn't right
I'm so confused
slightly messed up oh okay section
sneeze over here okay there we go all
right so now you will go up we will
should send something with it ah grim I
paired it this is your lucky day
oh my god gah bro make me proud go up no
oh [ __ ] yeah what do you want from me
spin new elephant okay I'm spinning I'm
spinning
Berner stop doing anything what whoa gob
rum I see you on the other side oh no we
are in Section C I don't even remember
what I'm doing here
key all right mr. chef what are you
doing all right some batteries would be
you know pretty sweet all right it's
supposed to be in here oh there it is
all I need to do head back up all right
I guess I'll do that Jesus Christ I did
a lot of things in it right in I did
something bro I'm deaf
hi dad ha ha ha I working with him no
that's [ __ ] ass oh no the [ __ ] around
I even try to dodge it way all right so
we're heading back right
all right let's continue our journey I
have no [ __ ] clue why I don't know
I'm not really enjoying playing this
anymore right now all right
one of these doors maybe this one oh
that means did you do yeah don't take
this wall right now why did I do that
I'm so stupid run fast to the vini
cellar
there we go second time hiding up there
[Laughter]
jump w up tripping up oh alright alright
so I really have to end here sorry it
was a little weird left sir but anyway
like a favors you enjoyed subscribe to
come a birthday see you next episode of
I move Wow time just flies by when
you're playing them I mean I gotta tell
you but dead anyway